good morning and it's pleasure to be
with you and thank you for inviting me
to present on the impact of new covert
19 variants and the vaccine roll out on
the pandemic
[Music]
i will briefly talk about
excess mortality which is very important
as we measure the impact of covert 19
then move very quick to covert 19
projections uh
tell you briefly how we do the
projections
talk a little bit about the new variants
and the impact
on the pandemic of course uh the role
out of the vaccine and the impact on
pandemic and then briefly talk uh
provide a summary at the end of my
presentation
as you all know we do at ihme the global
burden of disease where we provide
what are the causes of death and also
the risk factors attributing to deaths
and injuries
and in order to do so for gbd 2020 we
have to
get accurately how many cobra 19 cases
have been how much mortality and of
course to get a disability weight
around it so it's very important for us
not to take the deaths that have been
reported
but to capture all the deaths that have
happened uh during
the covert 19 pandemic all over the
country
and what i'm showing you a couple of
slides here is work in progress we
haven't finalized it right now
but we have about 50 or 60 countries
where we have good data
about how many cases how many cases and
how many deaths
from covert 19 have been reported and we
have actually the best records that we
can
even look at them and see how much
covert 19 was under reported
mortality and of course our assumption
here that covert 19 mortality was
more likely to happen and be under
reported
early on during the pandemic because of
course as you know when the first wave
had
people who were more at a high risk they
didn't know that cover 19 is circulating
and unfortunately
none of us was wearing a mask at that
time so we would have
much more deaths especially like among
the vulnerable population
we've seen it in many countries and
nursing homes
this is what we are looking at right now
we see a lot of
uh access mortality in many parts of
africa
many parts of asia to lesser extent
in the united states and in europe
russia has a good reporting system but
still there is excess mortality in every
country in the world
and there have been some studies showing
that there are excess mortality
that have not been reported indonesia
for example you have a high
unreported death of over 19.
and in our early analysis right now
we're seeing a huge difference between
what has been reported and deaths of
kobat 19 and what has
actually occurred and to give you an
idea that this is by
different regions in the world and you
could see the num
total number of deaths that have been
reported with about 2 million deaths
right now 2.4 million deaths you could
see here that we have
much more higher number of deaths right
now maybe three folds when it comes to
corporate 19.
and to simply look at it in some of the
countries take for example the united
states with
with about less right now than 500
thousand deaths in the u.s we're
estimating about seven hundred and
sixteen thousand
thousand deaths in the united states so
in a country like ours where we have
good
vital registration we have under
reported
deaths from government 19 and we have
seen that cdc reported last year
covert 19 2020 was the third leading
cause of death so
of course it's a high level of mortality
but also
underreported especially early on
because we were not doing enough testing
in many countries
in the world let me now move uh
briefly to talk about our covert 19
projections and some of you who have
seen me presenting to
this group may have seen some of these
slides but i want to briefly tell you
how we do it because it has a lot of
implications on what i'm going to
present
on the impact of covert 19 vaccines and
new violence occurred 19th and that
covert 19 projections
started at the request of our medical
center udub medicine
and they wanted to know how many beds
they need to prepare
how many ventilators and icu and
as all of you remember in the united
states the first case was diagnosed here
first death was diagnosed here in
seattle
in our catchment area and we had a lot
of deaths early on in the nursing homes
here
and we started doing this at the request
do we get four incontinence nahomish
county where seattle is
and the rest of the state and started
doing it for every country in the world
and that's very important when we do
this for every country in the world
we could see patterns and we were able
for example
to predict in the u.s research this
winter last winter
because we had seen a surge in winter in
argentina in the southern hemisphere
where cases kept going up even with all
the measures put in place strict
social distancing mandate and high level
of mask wearing so we looked at the
association why winter
and of course we determined that it is a
seasonal virus
and it's acting up more and more like
pneumonia
not like flu like pneumonia because
pneumonia doesn't go down totally in
summer and we've had searches
uncovered 19 and summer right now a
search in summer from covert 19 in
brazil for example
in their summer and our model has
evolved right now within the third
version of our model
briefly our model takes uh
early on let me say early on we did not
use the susceptible exposed infected and
remove modern s e r s as eir
models because we didn't have lots of
testing so we didn't know how many
people have been infected
so we used mortality and used a curve
fit
and we backward from mortality to
infection
and need for hostilization bad etc so we
looked for each desk how many
hospitalization had been
and then we counted the deaths and went
backward and then we projected the
deaths all the way up
and we that model did extremely well in
predicting the peak but
failed and predicting the decline simply
in the united states at that time it was
building
its priors on the experience we have
seen in china italy and spain and south
korea where the
pandemic went up and came down symmetric
epidemic happy curve
it wasn't true in the us simply because
we had premature opening in the united
states so we had the bumpy decline and
then we had to shift all these models
right now this e i
our model and random knots that we do in
order to get the curve
uh we use in our models several
variables uh
mask use we use cell phone mobility data
now we don't have to use only mandate
which we use and our model but we know
mobility so we know the impact of a
mandate on a mobility
whereas in the previous model and the
early model we assumed the mandate will
have the same effect everywhere we know
that's not true right now
different mandate in different states or
different locations
have contributed to less decrease in
mobility sometimes
and we've seen we have data on that
pneumonia seasonality testing of course
particulate matter because this is a
lung disease
altitude and of course pneumonia death
rate
and all what i'm presenting when it
comes to the covert 19 is available on
our web we have a covert 19 projections
we put our outfit
articles out there scientific articles
our policy brief
frequently asked question and you can
download the estimates
and all the data is available on
cobithealth.org
healthdata.org just to give you an idea
this is
a good example where california for
example we have good data and
many states here and it's a large
state the largest state in the united
states but you still see
how much variation from day to day when
it comes to the data
if you're looking at cases here green
hospitalization blue and red dust
you could see how noisy the data is so
and we have a weak end effect we have
the holiday effect right now after
easter we have the holiday effect
we have less reported death cases on
saturday and sunday on
monday sometimes on tuesday and it picks
up that and
towards the end of the week then starts
coming down
and hostilization is the same way so we
have to do a lot of work in order to
clean the data and smooth the data
imagine a smaller state in the us and
the major countries where also they
don't have as good
reporting system like we have here in
the united states
hostilization is good in the united
states
because hospitals have electronic
reporting but again there are
disparities in remote area where the
hospitals do not have that capacity
uh so there is a huge variation of
course between one state to another
[Music]
we also uh get vaccine hesitancy and we
have a
huge problem large problems when it
comes to vaccine hesitancy
even in the united states where we are
about 25 percent of americans are
telling us we will not take the vaccine
and about 70 70 75 percent and varies by
state are saying we will take the
vaccine or we are considering to take
the vaccine
yes i may take it and we have people who
say
no i will not may not take it and no one
i will not take it for sure so we
monitor all of this because it's very
important in our projections and of
course we wanted the supply of the
vaccine many vaccines we're going to
receive how much
how many vaccines each country has
secured and when they were received and
promised by the
pharmaceutical companies we also monitor
how percentage of people infected and
that's very important and you will see
in later on in the presentation why it's
very important so how many people have
been
infected and we have zero programs
surveys that we use and right now we
know that
antibodies will decline with time so
i'll talk a little bit how we're trying
to adjust for that but it's very
important for all of us to know
how many people have been infected when
you look at herd immunity
because it's very important to know
infected plus
vaccinated so you know where you are
whether you stand
in terms of further immunity and here
for example if you look at
what's happening in south africa for
example and in brazil where we have
a lot of locations in brazil where the
infection is
over 50 percent and amazonas for example
in monash
60 percent in fact that still they have
an outbreak when they have the new
variant that pete
p1p2 variant that came later on so
keeping an eye on what the percentage of
infected people in each country from
zero prevalence survey is very important
and we do that
actually let me talk about the new
variance and the complexity of working
with the new balance and i'll briefly do
that and i'll present on the impact on
global we have
these analysis with seeking
more data and i'll tell you why it has
been a little bit of challenge but we
have
some ideas of where we are heading and
what the impact of the variants
and vaccines
depend on so if you look i'm just giving
you examples here if you look for
example take an example from nigeria
blood bank studies
show that they have high zero problems
but at the same time
we don't have many cases being reported
and there is a low
a standardized infection fatality rate
so
so it's contradictory here the one one
is telling you there's been a lot of
infection but people are not dying from
it and that is under reporting of this
and even in good places where we have
good data in nigeria
they don't add up so something is
happening there just i'm giving you an
idea
uh winning sensitivity of the antibodies
test so one of the tests sensitivity is
coming decline and it varies by the test
and also
depending on when you test there is a
decline in antibodies so you don't
know what's the true percentage of
infection because it depends on the
decline of antibodies and
when you do your tests and the blood so
and previously infected individual
makes a little bit more complicated in
the analysis because
if the previous infection and we have
seen that right now
the good example i gave you is briefly
in brazil and south africa
where the infection was very high and
when the new variant in south africa
v1351
showed up and the p1 in brazil and later
the p2
we still see outbreak and highly
infected previously infected people even
from zero
prevalence surveys so if you've taken
monash for sixty percent and you've seen
outbreak and death so here is the
question
is the new new variant
does not provide immunity so previous
infection does not provide immunity
against the new variant so that's one
two the new variant makes the vaccine
less effective
so that's another thing that you want to
take into account
is the new variant more likely to spread
faster and increase infection
or the fact that the new variant there
is no cross immunity
it's gonna in fact as we have started a
new
epidemic in that location so these two
we don't know which one is
taking over is it the fact that you
don't have communities simply from
previous infection to this new one
or is the new one more likely to be
infectious and it will spread faster and
finding that balance takes a lot of
analysis
and we need data to be able to compare
it so there's
so many questions here that we need to
get right in order to make sure
what we are seeing is a true increase in
infection
is it the fact that there is no immunity
before to this new variant or is it the
combination of the two
so we we use for example
uh gis aid where everybody put
in in it once they do a genomic
surveillance of their
[Music]
circulating covert 19 and then also it's
under reported so for example
uh the minister of health and
uh turkey i don't speak uh turkish but
uh tweeted that they have 40 000 cases
of b1117
they identified we didn't see it on gis
data so there are a lot of information
out there
that sometimes high officials you know
who know what they are doing
come up and say it and we don't have the
data on it so
sometimes it's very hard to get
credible estimates in many places and
there is a delay between sequencing and
reporting
so we looked also in in addition to the
gis aid data we look at
how close countries are to each other so
when it's circulating in south africa
has been picked up
so we give more validity to somebody
next door to south africa to say oh i've
detected b135
v1351 same here in the us if we find it
circulating in one state we say okay
that's more credible that's now
circulating in the next state and so on
so it's very important to do that now
our colleagues in england have done a
very good job by the way many countries
do more genomic sequencing than we do
here in the united states who still are
not doing enough to know what's
circulating here
and right now in the united states if
you look at cdc what page the
variant that they are keeping an eye on
for example is the two one in california
two one in new york
the b1351 b117
and p1p2 from
brazil but for example california
announced
three days ago they have detected the
new variant that came from
india and it's a combination of what was
circulating in california and uh
p1p2 or v1351 so it has a combination of
the escape variants that we have seen in
south africa and
in brazil so there is not enough testing
but
in the uk they've done a lot of testing
and also they've done follow-ups
we know for example when v117 was
introduced what was circulating and they
followed
up that so we know how when v117 came
into play
how did it react or interact with other
valiants and which one became the most
dominant and how
it moved throughout the time so that has
helped us a lot
and in many european countries when b117
spread
how it moved faster was in these
countries so with more information about
b117
then we do have about b1351
or p1 simply because of the history it
happened v117
started in the uk where they're doing a
lot of testing
whereas the p1p2 started in brazil and
they're not doing enough of genomic
surveillance so that has a lot of
consequences on what
will be presented and we track this
variant so if you look like now
on on our web page you'll see the
prevalence of these
circulating variants all over the world
so of course v117 is the most
circulating one
in europe middle east and now in the
united states
the most dominant one in the united
states right now yv117
what we have seen in europe uh when it
came
about it basically overwhelmed
all the other mutations or took over and
then it's the one that's spreading so
it's pressing others one spread
and that's its expenses it's spreading
much faster and taking over in many
countries where it is
and there the b-1351 is spreading in
africa and certain parts
and asia right now arrived to europe
less so in the united states in terms of
take hold but we have
been detecting b1351 in many states and
the u.s but in our models
unless we get five locally we don't
start the counting all the way up we say
it's not
yet circulating and it's important and
then once we detect
five then we'll take it to another level
and we start
the spreads and that location and i'll
tell you how we do it and of course the
p1p2 started in brazil it's all over
south america and now
unexpectedly you know it's in florida
and
north east and because of the relation
of course miami airport and
going to south america
so there's a we have a lot of data right
now there is a reduced cross-valiant
immunity and i'm
trying to explain this before i go to
the model so we know for example in
novabax
trial in south africa under placebo arm
that was 3.9 percent and covered the
antibodies positive and negative so
basically
in their arm
[Music]
and there were people who were zero
positive so people who were infected
people were not in fact
but still the v1351 that back rate or
the infection rate was 3.9 percent
in both groups so previous zero block uh
prevalence didn't protest so there was
no cross community from the previous one
that's frazenica trial and uh showed
that there is a reduction
but there is about thirty-seven percent
not 100 percent you have seven percent
protection
against the new planet in uh south
africa
once you have been infected before so
zero to thirty seven percent
with the confidence interval to be zero
to fifty percent or
none of course so that's very important
to keep that in mind and then when you
look at the surgeon amazonas
and managing the rule in many locations
where i have showed you that fraction is
very high and that tells you there is no
cross
variant immunity so these are escape
variants they're not
they don't have we don't have immunity
against them who have been infected
before
and of course if there is a profound
decline
in uh in cross immunity then there is
unlikely that means will be harder to
get and that's very important
but the concern here is not only that
the new variance
we don't have immunity against that
gross immunity
the the concern here is they will make
the vaccines less effective so we have
published this
and there have been a lot of studies
since this so there's some updates to
this one but let me tell you what we had
before
and now i can show you some of the i can
tell you as we go through it
what the what the difference are from
our estimate and what we have found in
real life
so for example you've known pfizer and
modern and they said 95 percent
effective 94
affected against preventing disease
that's very important
the way effectiveness was set is
preventing disease
but preventing infection is totally
different so we
aside 86 and 85 right now we know for
example for moderna that new study that
came out it was 90 percent
affected by this infection we had 86
percent with a confidence interval
around it from our own analysis here
and when you look at all these vaccines
so take astrazeneca for example and i
want to focus on astrazeneca because
the vaccine that we uh kovacs uh
has worked the most of it and it's the
most one that will be used in many
countries in the world so we ask about
300 million after zanika taxi
but it's not authorized here and you've
heard president biden said we want to
give it to canada and
mexico so if you look at that at 74
and we don't know 74 there's been a lot
of issues with the clinical trial for
astrazeneca 74
we know it's 52 percent when it comes to
premature infection but
the scary part and it was published in a
uh
in a in lancet that astrazeneca is 10
percent effective against preventing
v1351
and we've heard that south africa
stopped it for him for a while and they
have stopped it right now but it's nine
nine percent preventing infection from
b1351 so
these vaccines all of them including
fizer and modena
have less effectiveness about 72 percent
against
the new van escape variant the p1 the
1351 and less than that
62 percent in preventing infection so
still highly effective for a vaccine we
take about 50 percent
but again keep in mind that these
vaccines with new values coming up
that are escape variant that less likely
to be affected
especially if there is no cross-immunity
so why would the vaccine be
also better so it will decline its
effectiveness will decline so keeping
that in mind it's very important in what
we do
so now the hardest part is estimating
past infection
and because in order for us to build a
model and say what's the impact of the
new variant and the vaccine we need to
know how many people have been infected
in the past and of course there was no
zero prevalence surveys early on
we're doing it right now we're catching
what people are
what that's the prevalence at the time
cross-sectional survey
you know except for some european
countries are doing follow-up and some
of the clinical trials are testing
people right now to see
the declining in antibodies as as
they've been monitoring their people
have been under clinical trial
but you could you could now look at it
as the increase
and for example it's very hard to look
at the path but it's the increased
transmission for example in south africa
or amazonas
is due to the combination of increased
transmutability of the
variant and reduced cross-valence
immunity or
something else so that's the difficult
for us to go and do it and the
combination between the two is very hard
and we're using the experience and some
assumptions that what we have seen in
you
so let me briefly say that so what we're
doing right now in order to do this long
range projection and show you very long
range projections that we haven't
released but
this is a scientific presentation here
so we're assuming
as people get vaccinated and we have
survey data that's telling us that when
people are receiving their vaccine
they're telling us 25 of them are
telling us in the united states they
will not be wearing their mass and
you've seen that relaxation in the
united states like texas saying no more
mass mandates we would expect that the
mass
that there'll be decline in mass wearing
especially this summer
since the cases are coming down and
you're telling people be vigilant but
they look around cases are coming down
the staircase is coming down
this is coming down it's praying that
summer so very hard
so we're saying we have different uh
scenarios in our projection that the
mask wearing will decline the summer it
goes up again in winter and i'll give
you some scenarios
it will remain constant so people who
are wearing a mask will keep wearing a
mask
some you know some of them will drop it
there is a seasonal mask wearing where
in winter will all of us will come back
to the mass and because cases are going
up
and then we could provide the scale up
all the way to 95 percent in
places where the infection is very high
so we assume countries where infection
is very high
put them and they could hit the brakes
and say put them but seeing confidence
we're assuming
that people are saying probably yes
we'll take the vaccines one of our
scenarios
and we're saying even people who may say
probably i will not take it
we may be able to convince them to get
the vaccine so instead of
right now it's about 70 percent we'll
say maybe it's
more than 70 percent of americans will
be taking the vaccine
simply because those who pulled us
probably not about seven or eight
percent
they will take the vaccine and mobility
again we're assuming in july
and i'm talking about the us but it
varies of course by country depending on
the summer
on july 1st you know we'll go back
mobility like what we were doing before
those things would be very good or we
can return
to where we are in may first and then
we'll hold it all the way up and we know
from our data for example before the
mandates
were imposed when we got the mobility
data we know that people even before
there was any mandate in the united
states they stayed at home and mobility
declined
so another certain segment of the
population will be very careful unless
it's all clear they will not
relax in terms of mobility and mass
wearing and we take that and block them
so here uh the other thing about the
cross variant immunity because we've
seen 37 and
zero rubber backs 37 percent and
astrazeneca who said it to be zero to 50
percent this escape pattern
or for some variants it's 50 to 100
percent so there is
a cross immunity
we are entering in our models that will
have a booster that will address the
decline in vaccine that i showed you
effectiveness so
and we know fives and modern everybody
even astrazeneca is now
modifying the vaccine to be you know to
be able to be highly
more effective against the new planet so
that's very important
so we're taking that into account and
we've been asked also to add in our
projections which i'm not showing you
today that the vaccination will be
declined it will be in
lower temporalization to age 12 and 12
[Music]
and of course we're talking about
variance speed slow and fast we believe
different scenarios for that because
some of the variant speed we know v117
is very fast
some of the variant speed is much lower
although
they are escape variant like p1 and p2
we haven't seen them spread as fast as
what we have seen spreading
with b117 so basically v117
that's spreading so fast and not
allowing others to spread in a way
we have so many evils fighting but the
evil that's winning the lesser evil is
winning in a way
that's how i look at it sometimes that
b117 is
winning and there is no winning here but
it's overtaking
and we know the vaccines are much more
effective against it and it has some
cross immunity from previous impacts
so let me show you briefly some of our
long range and i'll take some time to
explain it here
so this is global this is all the whole
world and what you're looking at here
is the liveness previously what has been
happening and
in terms of uh daily infections and
daily deaths
and uh in daily infections the green one
that the showing
you before before we have to all the
options because
what our estimate of real infection and
the lower one
is what has been reported in faction
remember okay
every country under report and we have a
percent detection right that we use
for every country in order to do that
from uh
so look at the problem survey and say oh
you have 20 percent people in fact that
you said one percent impacted so
there is a factor of 20 here that you're
not able to catch
and we added for every country in the
world so some of the scenarios is very
pessimistic here that the cases will
increase and then we will have another
wave
and daily death would go up uh about to
30 000 deaths globally a day one of the
worst case scenarios sometimes in 2022
at the beginning of the year which is
the
european northern hemisphere winter
and let me talk about high acceptance of
the vaccine will be a little bit lower a
booster will be the blue so the
mortality will decline as you can see
especially in during the winter
the mortality was vaccine and a booster
will be
less or similar to what we have seen in
the mortality in december and january of
19
2020 and 2021 so that was a
high acceptance of the vaccine and the
booster so increasing the
allowing the people who say i may not
take the vaccine maybe not
to come and so that's what high
expectancies we say everybody who
says probably not will add them so high
expectancy and a boosted vaccine will be
much lower than what we have seen in the
previous
uh winter so basically for the us or
many countries in the world we have
high acceptance of the vaccine and we
could have a booster that we can develop
before
we hit the winter we could be
the mortality will never reach what it
has reached in last december and january
and that's very important
then no mobility look at low mobility
and the regular
vaccination is way lower than what we
have seen before so it's very
even infection much lower than what we
have seen before it's very important
it's mobility if people behave and stay
at home
uh and then especially during winter
that's that will reduce that fraction as
you can see here
and we'll reduce the mortality of course
with the vaccination that will help us a
lot in the united states
if we do mass mass are the most
effective tool we have right now not
everybody has
access to a vaccine right now but all of
us have an access to a massive it's
very important mass wearing is very
important if we continue mask wearing at
95
cases will be declining all the way to
our winter in the northern hemisphere
and in the united states may go up a
little bit but
never never to what we have seen before
and mortality will go up a little bit
but not as much as we have seen before
and then the most optimistic we're
hoping for is
all the good ones i've done in terms of
vaccines everybody take the vaccine
everybody take the
booster everybody who said i will take
it will take it we keep mobility low we
keep
mask wearing very high
this pandemic will start declining from
now on
all the way in the wood and then we will
not have a big
bump next uh winter
in the northern hemisphere and but you
see here
a july you see that jump in july that's
the
winter in the southern hemisphere which
is you will see a little bit of a rise
there and it will be
an increase mortality will increase a
little bit to what we have seen in our
winter in the northern hemisphere we'll
see it for the southern hemisphere
but it starts coming down after that if
again and again we do a very good job on
controlling this virus so these are the
scenarios we're looking at
so let me break them uh now by
same as above but let me break them down
one by one to look at them the impact so
if you look at global vaccine scenarios
assuming mobility returned to pre-cover
19 baseline in july
and mass queues returned to zero on july
1st
cross-valence into 0.5 transmission
escape minus is 0 to
50 of b117 and these are the scenarios
here we see that reference scenario what
we're saying there will happen
low hesitancy against the vaccine
booster and low hesitancy plus booster i
mean vaccines will play a big role
on their own here if holding everything
constant
if we are accepting the vaccine and we
take the vaccine i mean vaccines are our
only hope to get out of this pandemic is
to accept the vaccine and take the
vaccine
on time now let me look at mask use mask
as i'm keep insisting here and keep
reminding all of us that it's
very important to reduce the spread of
the virus simply because of the lack of
bug we don't have vaccines for everybody
right now
so if you look at flat mask again you
know if you keep the basket what we are
right now keep it flat
cases will keep coming from the bump in
july especially in the
southern hemisphere but it will come
down we see a rise here and
in the united states some vehicles of
oxygenality around the new year
the delays and because of the mass but
if we have a seasonal mass and we wear
the mask
it's not as good as the flat mask if we
drop it and wear it
no if you continue doing it it's much
better the green is much better than the
seasonal mask wearing here
and the best scenario if we keep the
vaccine at a higher
level yes we'll have a little bit of we
can control the pandemic everywhere it
may go up in northern america simply you
don't see it here going up
and southern global in the southern
hemisphere but you see it going up in
the northern atmosphere because we're
assuming right now
for the northern they have a good summer
they will even if the best case scenario
of their mask
would not be as vigilant as
if they didn't have that picture so
let me summarize here so
impact of new violence and the vaccine
vaccines are our only way out of the
of the corporate 19 and taking the
vaccine i mean that's a given i don't
have even to discuss that
but i hope people will hesitate we can
address it and make sure we go to
community where i'm at the source of
this residency and make sure people take
the vaccine
case and that's will increase do the new
variants in the united states we've seen
that it increased a little bit
in that bump in the road and it will
come down and so
cases and as we said with the new valley
nb107 cases will increase and this will
and we've seen it in some states right
now on the national level california
because they had it
locked down we didn't see a decrease and
i should have seen a bump in the road
but it's coming down in the world
but in many countries right now we will
see a rise in cases certainly because of
the bank b117 and pakistan and
bangladesh in many countries in the
middle east we're seeing a racist basis
and p1 of course
so we see a rise of cases unless we are
more visual
mobility seasonal mass and vaccines will
reduce the spread so
if we reduce our mobility and
seasonality right now in the northern
hemisphere will help us
mass fuels will help us and vaccine
vaccine hazardous is a big concern and
i'm concerned about astrazeneca
all the we've noticed in the u.s when
astrazeneca was pulled off the market in
europe we had
a slow i mean not much but we have a
little decline in uh vaccine acceptance
so vaccine hesitancy was about
25 percent of americans say they will
not take about 20 percent of momentum
were saying it won't take that valine in
certain location it increased a little
bit so in the u.s because 74 percent of
momentum say i will take the vaccine
point down to about 70 percent
so we've seen a variation by state
simply because the news of astrazeneca
although we don't have astrazeneca
it's not authorized in the united states
so i'm concerned with astrazeneca if it
has a low effectiveness and sp1
and b1351 and we're giving the vaccine
it will create a hesitancy especially
when we have a better vaccine coming up
or astrazeneca to revise its vaccine
so that creates a problem for us we need
a booster for sure
and i know many companies are working on
a booster right now from a
pharmaceutical company and
all of us are tired over 19 i mean
people want to go out and start
we're seeing an increase in mobility and
the economy i mean economy in many
countries are hit so hard so
they want to open the business and that
balance is delicate and fragile and very
difficult
so that's a big challenge as we move
the from a population health perspective
let's
prepare for the wars and hopefully it
will never happen so let's say in the
united states that
plan that this virus will be with us on
a regular basis for a while
now let's plan annually we need to get a
vaccine
we need to stay ahead of the variance we
need other that vaccine that takes into
account what's circulating in the u.s
with circulating elsewhere
so we need to do genomic surveillance
here to find out what's circulating in
our backyard but also what's circulating
elsewhere
and then keep improving our vaccine
not improving and making them attack the
new virus that we do is through every
year you know we tweak the flu vaccine
to make sure we're up to date on what
flu
strain is circulating and mutation is
circulating so that's the only way we
can stay ahead of this
virus this is all what i have thank you
very much this is my email if you have
any questions the
presentation will be available of course
the slide for everybody else once we
finalized the
excess mortality and the long term
projections we will release them but i
wanted to share with you what we're
coming
with what we're dealing with and how we
are trying to deal with it as we move
forward
and i joined the twitter
and i put some of these information on
twitter as well so which is for my
generation this is
a big jump for me to join the social
media and do that so
thank you very much everybody thank you
it was a pleasure talking to you